welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders this is no
20 minute leaders ordinary episode today
we're going to be having a panel with
some of the most amazing thinkers that
sit on boards of companies we're going
to be talking about communication we're
going to be talking about veto rights
we're going to be talking about
transparency welcome to more arbel
soldiers liat aaron sonja l benjamin and
nimrod roman please take the stage
welcome everyone this is so exciting
this is actually the first time that
we're hosting a panel of this sort
here on the show and i'm incredibly
honored to have all of you here it's
it's a really special you know event for
me to to get to know the insights from
four incredible incredible thinkers and
doers in the ecosystem here and today
we're going to be talking about
different sides of venture capital than
we often talk about a lot of the times
we talk about how to raise capital and
the different struggles of you know
reaching product market but this is not
the conversation this conversation is
about how do startups interact with the
venture capitalists with with board
members and we have here yell benjamin
lyatta once on the road roman and timur
are belgras all with uniquely different
perspectives some from research some
from board members some from the
entrepreneurial field and so we're going
to have a great time
getting to know each other and having
some fun conversations and
let's just quickly do around
getting to know all of you liat who are
you
who am i well i'm chairman of the
zell entrepreneurship program at lachman
university something i've been doing for
a long time for the last seven years and
10 years before that as executive
director and i'm also a co-founder and
the ceo of a blockchain startup called
horizon labs
incredible nimrod
um well i've been working with
entrepreneurs from the ideation phase
through to
the exit or wherever they get to
building big companies historically as a
corporate lawyer
and recently as a business consultant
through a consulting arm of our firm
called consilieri
amazing
timo
yeah so i am
the ceo of lumitec the high-tech arm of
lumi bank
a very recent in my
in my current job and before that
i was
for many years a managing partner at
biola credit which is a venture lending
arm a fund of viola group
and after working for so many years with
ceos and cfos in
growth the revenue stage
startups i thought i knew something
about startups and then i jumped into
into a startup myself being a ceo of the
fintech startup called everest
and then i learned
how much i didn't know
uh
so i came to luvitec both with the
experience of being a
fund manager and a board member
plus an executive in a startup company
beautiful and yael welcome
hi hi thank you so i'm the founder of
startup snapshot it's a data sharing
platform for the startup ecosystem and
we just did our fourth report which is
based on data from 300 founders and
board members around kind of the ceo
board dynamic
well this is what we're here to talk
about we have some fascinating topics to
uncover from from veto power and in
boards and transparency between startups
and the board itself and the
communication of how do we create this
transparency and then and then
communicate thoughtfully throughout the
journey yeah startup snapshot an
incredible project looking at the
ecosystem from a bird's eye view i've
been following it so closely and
enjoying the insight so much tell me a
little bit about the project and some of
the the high-level insights that you've
uncovered
yes so it's it's a project i started
working on about two years ago and kind
of our whole goal is to increase
transparency in the ecosystem so what
we're doing is we're collecting a lot of
data from founders we collected to date
over i think from 1 100 founders and we
share the insights with the entire
community so that everyone can kind of
benefit from this experience and
knowledge
that we have in the ecosystem and the
past couple of months we wanted to
really uncover insights on the board
what happens behind the closed doors of
the boardroom and today it's really
interesting you know today this topic is
super important with the you know the
growing size of the early stage rounds
so before you would have maybe two small
angel investors on your board and you
can have some kind of a you know
informal ad hoc discussion meeting a
cafe every once in a while update them
but now these same founders are raising
tens of millions of dollars and they
have large international funds on their
board and they're
unfortunately unfortunately you know
there's new kind of opportunities but
they're also meeting new challenges so
that's kind of what we wanted to
research the past couple of months and
we collected data from 300 founders and
their investors
and i'll just give a couple of like you
know small tidbits that were really
interesting here
so the number one thing was around
communication kind of how do you manage
this ongoing strategic communication
with board members and it's really
interesting 61 of ceos reported they're
not fully transparent with their board
so what are they doing they're sugar
coating difficulties they're waiting to
report certain challenges maybe trying
to find a solution before recording the
actual uh roadblock or challenge and
it's creating a lot of challenges so um
i think 36 percent of startups reported
that they have a challenging board
member
it's creating a lot of arguments
pushback vetoes unfortunately 28
reported that a board member has vetoed
a decision so board members are really
you know taking larger risk they're
pouring larger funds into earlier stage
companies but they're also asserting you
know asserting their control through
vetoes so that's on the one hand on the
other hand um you know due to the lack
of transparency startups aren't able to
maximize the value from their board
members
so
board members overestimated the value
they provide by around 20
so without kind of being open without
communicating in a really transparent
way without saying this is my challenge
this is the help i need from you
unfortunately startups aren't leveraging
this amazing asset that they have at
their fingertips
amazing and i can already see
liat
nodding their heads in agreement as as
we're touching the different topics that
they're going to be talking about nimrod
tell me a little bit about
you know the weapon of mass destruction
in one of the weapons of mass
destruction and perhaps in a startup
life or you know in in difficult moments
in which a veto may be exposed what what
is the veto and
and you know and i think in general you
know what you were talking about you
know a lot of these things i feel as
somebody from the ecosystem we don't
talk about enough at all and so i'm so
excited to dive deep into these
conversations with you nimrod tell me a
little bit about vetoes
okay well first of all i i i sort of
coined the phrase that you know the
exercising of a veto right is a weapon
of mass destruction or the use of a
weapon of mass destruction which is but
i said i mean
you know you you said it first and i i
slightly regret
you know introducing it as a term
but because um it's a little bit more
extreme but it gets you know it's like a
good click bait when you when you say it
but let's start with the academics
first of all
to understand what a veto right is you
sort of need to think about how
decisions are made in a company
decisions are made in a company in three
layers first of all on a daily basis
executives and managers make decisions
about their domain and they don't always
consult upwards
and sometimes they consult with a ceo
and that's another type of executive or
manager
within that domain the individual makes
the decision and there's no real
corporate law around that
then there are another two organs that
make decisions in the company the board
of directors and the shareholders
the shareholders are the sort of like
the highest organ and they make
decisions that are capitalistic in
nature and are you sort of in line with
their own interests
and the board is a bunch of people
elected by the shareholders
sometimes members represent investors
and sometimes members represent
management or founders and that organ
has to make decisions in the interests
of the company that's the default they
can't focus on their own personal
interests
by default by default now in those two
organs
the shareholders
and the board
the default is that decisions are made
by a majority
so if 51 of the shares or 50 plus of the
shares approved something anything
most corporate laws will support that
that decision will pass by the company
by that organ most corporate laws
if a board of let's say five people
had something
you know on the agenda and three members
of that board because board members
normally vote one vote per person and
not reflective of shareholdings again
there are exceptions to this rule but
let's talk about startups and they how
they behave then three people in that
five person board could approve the
decision
the veto right
is the ability of one or two individuals
in the board
obviously the investor appointed
directors
to say well despite the fact that you
got three people out of five we're still
blocking this thing or
at shareholder level it's the ability of
a certain um
group of shareholders normally the
holders of preferred shares the
investors
to say well despite the fact that you
lobbied the approval for this decision
let's say a financing round right of 50
plus of the shareholders we're still
blocking this because we are allowed to
block this pursuant to the
um documents that were signed when we
invested in the company
so
it's it creates this dynamic
where
basically bottom line the ceo
has a list of decisions
that he or she know that they cannot
pass without their investor support
now let's sort of stray from there for a
moment
in startups that work well
all decisions are approved by 100 of the
board members i very rarely have i seen
people vote against in startups that
work well really right
yeah because
because it cr it becomes a
a um
a due diligence problem if i show the
next investor that people are voting
against different decisions whether or
not there are vetoes
it becomes an issue for the company and
in future investment realms
so you agree that this is a form of
weakness that you mean we may have board
members who sometimes may be voting
against some some decisions yeah no in
my experience in boards i actually i'm
i'm fascinated by everything that nimrod
just said because i've been on
many boards and i've actually never seen
any of that dynamic
at play at all so i can't opine on it
what you mean that you haven't seen uh
decisions unanimously approved
no i haven't seen the veto of the the
weapon of mass destructive used
no of course
we're in total agreement what i was
saying was that in my experience
normally decisions are approved
unanimously everybody supports them
there's good communication
between the board members and people
support them however
the report shows
that
28 of managers have experienced
board members that have arrived at a
decision and said no we're vote we're
voting against and we're exercising our
veto right and frankly i was so
surprised by that as well that that's
why i said well that's a weapon of mass
destruction
that shows that that someone wasn't
ready for a discussion and that an
investor decided to block them decided
to block them and that's what i was
going to say because from my experience
it's not that everyone communicates so
well certainly not on a board meeting
level but what ends up happening is that
there's there's communication before
there's communication during there's
communication from the different levels
that you spoke about so
um
by the time that something comes up
there's some consensus built around it
and so i haven't seen uh decisions that
where someone comes and and flatly says
no in a board decision but i have
definitely seen
um i can i can completely relate to the
um to the statistic that talks about a
um a kind of a problematic board member
or someone that comes in and either
you know
kind of makes the meeting a little bit
more aggressive or more contentious
so it's not about the voting it's more
about
kind of the management of the meeting
itself and and maybe a lot of the back
end and kind of back channeling that
goes around that
yeah i mean
i i i fully agree
this is where the report i think was
included a very important insight i've
personally witnessed many boards that
included challenging board members
but then when management understood that
a decision that they were about to pass
wasn't going to pass unanimously they
decided not to really bring it for
approval so that it didn't you know put
the company in a situation where it
disapproved and now let's be very
practical for a moment because you know
this is the topic that i thought i was
gonna elaborate on
in the board
a decision like that let's put aside a
financing transaction or an exit which
is mostly what founders dream about
let's say the hiring of an executive
which requires the grant of a certain
number of options
and the number of options seems high to
the board members represented by the
investor and then there's a challenge
around that or a budget approval
um
if in 28 of companies clearly not the
companies that we've been involved in
um they got to a point where somebody
said no this is not approved and sort of
sent the ceo back to the hire to the
executive and to tell them well you
didn't get your options too bad
or set or or disapprove the budget those
situations are extreme
what they show
is that
either the ceo pushed too hard to pass
the item on the agenda
um without having prepared all of their
board members first for the discussion
beforehand which is a critical
you know uh piece in the process but it
also shows that there was an investor
who was cavalier enough
to say i don't care what this shows in
due diligence
i'm going to still stamp the the no on
this this is going to show that i didn't
support management which is a
i think that raises an interesting
question it's interesting for me to see
what you think about it whose
responsibility is it to prevent vetoes
is it more on the side of the
entrepreneur that has to communicate
ahead of time has to decide ahead of
time what they're going to bring up for
approval or on the side of the investor
that obviously wants um future funding
rounds to go well
well all right
sorry go ahead tomorrow all right i
think at the end of the day this is the
this is the job of the ceo
100 to bring yeah
to work with the board members or even
to manage
uh the board uh in in a way that doesn't
bring uh
issues to the point where decisions need
to be taken so that would require you
know one-on-ones that would require
uh non-formal board discussions in order
to uh you know to get into compromises
or agreements or to work
like enumerates
example about a budget
so to work uh together
non-formally on the budget until we get
to a um a solution that everybody's in
agreement with i think that getting into
a situation of veto
or uh board members that object to
decisions is really bad to the campaign
well we're gonna we're gonna leave the
conversation here and i'm sorry anymore
but we have we have to move on to the
other topics but we have already another
panel scheduled and you're get and we're
gonna have to revisit this conversation
and i think this is a perfect segway
team over to to talking about you know
this this idea of managing the board and
being able to communicate well and the
discussion of communication has to start
with this idea of transparency and this
idea of how do we actually instead of no
the the foundation of managing the board
is first to be able to get the board to
understand what's happening and to be
able to be open and authentic about
what's going on in the status liat what
has been your experience or and your
observations with the way that
entrepreneurs make the shift from wooing
the investor to now you know working
with them as a partner
yeah it's a great segue actually to the
other topic as well because it's um i
agree with timur
that it's 100
um the ceo's job to manage this
situation what i think happens
after our founding round is that there's
a psychology
where the entrepreneur that was so busy
um in a sales mode trying to you know
put the best face forward the you know
lipstick on the gorilla and making it
look really really really pretty uh
making sure no one's looking under the
hood
um and then all of a sudden
once the investors ma once once the
investment's made and i've literally
seen an investor tell an entrepreneur um
like dude i'm already invested
i'm in this now so go ahead and you know
open the hood it's okay i'm in
and i think what happens is that shift
it's it's an amazing opportunity not
everyone's able to do it but the amazing
opportunity is for an entrepreneur to
take from sales mode to
now i have this asset this this up this
kind of opportunity for an asset to be
able to use the wisdom the experience
the connections everything that the
investor is bringing in
in order to actually
share the real problems and you know
voice the real concerns and
and and kind of going back to the other
discussion i've seen boards that are
managed by a ceo and i've seen boards
that are managed by the investors and
clearly
being managed by the ceo is the right
way to go and a ceo that really
appreciates that and is able to be
transparent do the communications with
each investor ahead of the board meeting
and manage the board meeting through
that transparency and actually being
able to use that incredible resource
i love that i love that
thoughts on this idea of being able to
make that shift from personal
experiences or observations
i i think that it's important to to
remember like for for ceos and cfos and
entrepreneurs uh
to to try and imagine the situation from
the
um
from the viewpoint of the investor
because it's important to to to realize
that vc is not a scalable
business right because each partner has
a certain amount of
companies that they can be involved with
and so imagine a board member that sits
like on on boards of eight companies
and
unlike the executives in the company and
entrepreneurs that you know they live
day by day the reality of the of the
company and the challenges and the wins
and the successes and the losses and the
board members pops in once every while
it can be once a week once a month once
a quarter depends on the on the company
and they need to
to help the company to make the right
decision or even maybe only to ask the
right questions
and for them to be able to do that and
to really
help the company with their
experience and abilities
they need to be able to quickly
understand the situation and the
challenges that the company faces
and
one of the
ways we talked about transparency so
this is one way of doing that and the
other way is to use the language that
the board member can easily understand
so if
there are some standards
we see you know the standard um
financial
terms or um
or indicators like for example it's very
it's very uh popular for sas companies
right there are the standards uh metrics
that people are looking at if you're
using the standard uh the student terms
and they started in the standard kpis
it's much easier
for a board member to get to grasp the
reality the challenges the opportunities
very very quickly and to be able to uh
to help so i think
for a young
uh
managers it's very important to take the
time and learn the language uh that the
board members are are used to
work with you know even even the
simplest things do you show your plan on
a monthly basis or on a quarterly basis
on or on a yearly basis
we are so used to see stuff on a
quarterly basis that sometimes when they
if they show it to you on a monthly
basis it takes you a while to grasp the
trends of what this
every every number means
uh this is i think
sorry yeah no and i think i think that's
a great point i think it's not only um
you know what kind of metrics make sense
but it's also what kind of language so
if it's a more technical
um you know an investor with a more
technological background that's more
interested in in the product and the
technology then you kind of take that
conversation if it's someone who's
really only interested in the excel then
you you know you don't talk about the
challenges of
of your development you know your um
developers and the product development
piece you go straight to the numbers so
i think investors are also you know they
want to bring what they have to the
table but they definitely don't want to
be put out of their comfort zone and try
to opine on things that they don't know
what to open on
and actually not very useful for the
company either
definitely i think based on what you
said also you have to understand what
are the strengths of each of your
investors and kind of ask them for help
in that specific domain of where they
can help to kind of manage the the help
that they can give you i think one of
the interesting stats that we found is
that 81 of investors said they really
want to get specific tasks from their
portfolio companies basically make this
in this intro you know this executive
but uh the majority seventy percent of
founders said they don't feel
comfortable asking for help in that way
so it's really a missed opportunity you
have to understand what are the
strengths of your of your board and who
can help you with different types of
things and really after every meeting
after every email kind of reach out and
ask for that help
i'm seeing your eyes popping out of your
head
yeah well
i want to you know i first of all i i
yeah i've been i've been waiting i fully
agree
um
sort of like to view the world in terms
of what's like the default situation or
the ideal situation
and what reality warrants
and i i hope timor and don't kill me for
this but i but i but i want to take a
different approach
up until two years ago i would have
agreed wholeheartedly with everything
that was said up until now i think the
company's life cycle was seven to nine
years
and people were expected just to
gradually increase in valuation
and utilize amounts of money
in a more sort of gradual manner
and grow into it grow into the ceo
position and then you could totally be
disappointed if they missed on using the
board members or on terminology etc
investors who get paid a lot of money
for their jobs um
and invest in hundreds of companies are
dumping over the last two years
tens of millions of dollars on ceos
who they know and i know and we know
have never managed budgets of tens of
millions of dollars all they came with
was a hot idea in cyber a general
understanding of the market
and it's a long time ago that we started
investing in companies that are already
second year or third tier the best
companies go to the tier one investors
um
and uh and that's where you get also the
sort of the roundest founders who are
repeat founders and know how to avoid
situations
i want to see any tier 2 fund downwards
who know they are tier 2 funds
allocating additional investment amounts
at higher valuations for founder growth
for mentorship for actual business
courses
the expectation that founders come into
the position of a ceo like the leonardo
da vinci of managers
is is is ideal
and it's certainly the case when you
know when when you're not you know sort
of pushing uh the founder to take i've
seen companies take this year alone of a
term sheet for an a round and b served
and encouraged to close a deal for a
growth round four months later we've
seen that many times
those ceos if they don't get like
monetary support i'm not only talking
about the investor because timor is
right investor has eight board members
i'm talking about a value creation fund
outside of the vc additional cash
to invest in this growth otherwise it's
not going to come from these people
there are young individuals i manage
conciliarity to start up i don't have an
idea always you know i can talk about my
clients or about certain aspects of the
business but if they don't you know
literally pay to teach me it's not going
to happen and then it only and then the
dynamic in the board
sort of
hinges on the personal relationships and
because i know t-more and i know lyad
and i know their experience and their
access to companies i have no doubt that
they've had really good correspondences
with companies they've invested in but
there's such a long tale of companies
that take money from a long tail of
investors
from a longer tale of investors where
unfortunately that's not the dynamic and
in those companies in those companies in
that long tail i'm putting it solely on
the investors they gave the money
they're cutting the management fee they
need to support the ceos because they
genuinely came up with an idea and um
you know they're hoping to make it work
and for the company to succeed all the
stars need to align
there's a difference between the cream
of the crop and people that are growing
into it that's all i'm saying but yeah
it's responsible you know with all the
respect to board members the ceo is
responsible for the success of the
company and i
agree with you
that you know ceos especially these days
where you you see young ceos and young
companies facing mature funds
and and and
very um
large amounts of of investments
uh it is
this is at the end of the day business
of trust and the ceo that wants to
succeed needs to find a way to create
distress and yes ask for the mentorship
or demand the the
mentorship but in the end of the day i
think this is the ceo's job
well the investors they need to help
okay it's their uh interest best of best
interest right but it's
this is the the ceo's responsibility to
demand this mentorship to to find the
way to grow very quickly as quickly as
the company grows
i'm not arguing with that but 70 of the
ceos don't approach them according to
this thing yeah so some people are
approachable maybe maybe the people here
i'm approachable you're approachable
those who aren't approachable
you know they're they spin it they need
to call it and they need to be
approachable
there are ways to do that
i think i love that you think that all
of the boards that i've been on are like
uh happy happy clearly that's not in the
reality plus through the zell program
i've been involved
through
some of these younger founders
through a lot of other board dynamics as
well and i still completely agree with
timo at the end of the day
it's the ceo backed by his co-founders
that support him that has to manage the
relationship it's not only about they
can be young and inexperienced and still
it's a psychology it's a it's an
exercise in psychology more than it is
about knowing what the right decisions
are now
i think that that leap that jump to
being able to use the board numbers is
important but really a company that's
going to be run by its board is
to me inherently um
in a challenging situation like a really
truly challenging situation um and i've
seen that as well i i don't think um
i i think ultimately the ceo needs to to
manage to make use of the investors and
frankly investors are investors they
they you know i think they need to know
how to raise the money choose good deals
and help them get to exit i think they
overthink themselves if they think that
they're going to be so instrumental in
actually running the company if they
need to run the company i think houston
we have a problem we are we're
continuing exactly where we left off
tomorrow
finish off our conversation about board
members and serves but this is just the
beginning because i think we're gonna
have to have many more of these
conversations moving forward timo
how can startups better standardize
communication between the startup
founders and the executive team with
board members that sometimes are sitting
on eight different boards and don't have
time to
constantly be thinking about the startup
so so we are we're we talked about
really trust and since there it's a big
issue at the beginning especially these
days when
when we see young startups raise a lot
of money and so they don't start
the company with angels but rather with
very professional investors and they
need to find a way
to communicate and build this trust
in a way that is not too demanding time
demanding from
uh the the ceo of the ceo at the end of
the day to focus to be laser focused on
growing the business right
and we see ridiculous uh
demands coming from investors that
didn't build trust like weekly calls
with the ceos and we imagine the ceo
needs to do weekly calls one-on-one with
five different board members every week
or every month this is
this is ridiculous and this is hurtful
for the company so um creating some kind
of a format
for updating them and aligning
expectations
on what important
issues need to be
to be reported and making a scheme
a format of for example a report with
the important factors uh would be very
beneficial in in this stage and i would
strongly strongly recommend those young
ceos uh to get help from from
experienced
financial managers
with either within the company or as a
consultant or as a mentor to help
building it correctly and then
maintaining it it's it gets much easier
once you have it
in place
i love it
i'll just throw out a shout out here so
at horizon labs we are super fortunate
to be
um
uh
to have dcd
digital currency group as an investor
and barry silbert is um is uh the lead
investor there and he
um and dcg cup has a format for us to
fill in on a you know
uh it's actually a quarterly basis and
it's super
clear and concise and asks for the exact
information that they want to get and
information that we know how to compile
for them and it makes for really really
easy communication so
i completely agree to more from the
founders side as a founder i can say
it's amazing
i love it and i will really want to
thank all of you here for for joining
and this was
so much fun y'all thank you so much for
putting this together and thank you
more for joining us and for taking part
in this in incredible conversation this
is a start of many more and i learned an
incredible amount and and i can't wait
to share this with with all my friends
and with everybody in the ecosystem it's
gonna be fantastic and stay safe and
stay healthy everyone thank you
me too cheers thank you very much thanks
michael thank you thanks leah tim timur
you